you're listening to an encore
presentation of Bible answers live
however if you want to order any
materials offered during tonight's
program you may call our resource number
anytime at $887 live where you'll get
honest answers to your Bible questions
let's face it it's not always easy to
understand everything you read in the
Bible with 66 books and more than 700
thousand words the Bible can generate a
lot of questions if you'd like answers
to your Bible questions you've come to
the right place now here's your host
pastor Doug Batchelor president and
Speaker of amazing facts you know I
haven't told too many people my personal
testimony on the radio but I was raised
pretty much an atheist and got into a
lot of trouble when I was growing up
mother was Jewish Jewish background but
not religious father was from a Baptist
background but they were both pretty
much agnostic as I was growing up and I
had no idea about God did the typical
teenage thing in the 60s where I I got
into trouble and was thrown in jail and
got involved in drugs and trouble in
school eventually I ran away from home I
was hitchhiking around the country and I
landed in a cave I wanted to live like a
hermit and find God through nature or
see if there was something in nature
that would teach me the truth I ended up
moving into a cave way up in the
mountains above Palm Springs California
and I lived like that sort of like a
hermit for about a year and a half and
then at the end of that time I was
transformed and the reason is when I
moved into that cave somebody had put a
Bible in the cave that totally changed
my life
at first I had problems because you know
I was reading the Bible and it was a
King James Bible somebody had left up
there we didn't speak King James English
in New York when I was growing up so I
trouble with some of the wording but as
I kept studying the Word of God
it just it began to make changes in my
heart and gradually I thought well how
can this be true I went down to a
librarian I said did Jesus actually live
and sure enough it said that Jesus did
live and so I was faced with really
three choices I was so moved by the
things that Jesus said in the Bible I
said well either he was crazy
or he was a liar or he was telling the
truth
I think it's CS Lewis who said that
Jesus is either liar lunatic or Lord you
only have one of those three options and
I knew it wasn't a liar because
everything he did was all about truth
and it has resonated as truth and he
said I am the truth Christ claim to
actually be the embodiment of the truth
I knew he wasn't a deceiver crazy
because everything he said just seemed
to be so centered and makes so much
sense and as I was reading through them
through the Bible I was actually amazed
how many times I would read these famous
quotes and I had no idea that came from
Jesus like words said turn the other
cheek or cast the first hymn without sin
cast the first stone and and going the
Second Mile and all these famous sayings
of Christ I thought wow he was brilliant
he's the one that said all those things
so I was convinced Jesus wasn't crazy
the only option I had left is that he
was telling the truth and so eventually
I got on my knees and said Lord if the
Bible is true will you come into my life
and give me some purpose for living now
when I knelt up there in the mountains
in that cave living by myself
I was about as far from God as a person
can be I mean I was running around up in
the mountains I didn't wear any clothes
up there I was eating out of garbage
cans when I came down to town and just
you know using drugs and lying living it
morally there I was a big zero but when
I found the Bible and when I gave my
heart to Jesus everything began to
change
so there's power in the Word of God and
Friends if you've not tried it and I'd
recommend you start all right stay with
us friends we're going to learn more on
this edition of Bible answers live
[Music]
you're listening to Bible answers live
honest answers to your Bible questions
this broadcast is a previously recorded
episode to receive any of the Bible
resources mentioned in this evening's
program call 888-814-3923 Pastor John
Ross is not in tonight he's driving
somewhere between the East Coast and the
west coast of the United States and so
we're going to start the program as we
always do with a word of Prayer father
in heaven thank you for your many
blessings Lord we thank you for the
truth that sets us free and I pray Lord
that you'll bless tonight's program we
ask that you be with those who are
calling in and that the Holy Spirit will
make the appointments with the very
questions that come in and that lives
are changed in the process we thank you
and ask all this in Jesus name Amen
now I don't know friends if you've ever
fasted before I think the most I've gone
is two or three days without food you
can actually after a couple of days you
stop thinking about it and you know I've
heard of people course the Bible tells
us Jesus went forty days without eating
the Bible tells us that Elijah went
forty days and forty nights without
eating but what's really amazing is that
Moses and you read this in Exodus 34
verse 28 when he went up on Mount Sinai
to receive the Ten Commandments there in
the presence of the Lord it says so he
was there with the Lord
forty days and forty nights
he neither ate bread or drank water and
God then wrote the Ten Commandments on
those two tables of stone for him now I
heard about a man that during a hunger
strike he went up to 80 days and this
was back in Ireland when they were
protesting with the IRA and eventually
he didn't I of hunger Gandhi would go on
long fasts trying to make a political
statement and others have but you know
very few people could last very long
without food but Jesus said in Matthew
chapter 4 man doesn't live by bread
alone but by every word that proceeds
from the mouth of God and if we are
being fed by God that gives us the
spiritual nutrition that we really need
for eternal life you know the Bible is
pretty clear jesus said the words that I
speak they are bread they are life the
disciples once said Laura takes
something to eat well he had just left
he had just led the Samaritan woman to a
knowledge of who he was and he was so
excited about it
he said I've got food you don't know
about my food is to do the will of my
father in heaven and there really is
satisfaction that comes to us from doing
God's will friends are you eating the
bread of life you can't live very long
spiritually with that you know in the
Lord's Prayer it says give us this day
our daily bread now that not only means
we're supposed to be praying every day
for our physical food but it means we're
supposed to be praying for the spiritual
food as well and I hope that you'll do
that you know we do have a study guide
we'd like to offer to anyone that asks
tonight and it is dealing with the Word
of God if you'd like to know how to have
that Bread of Life
it's is there anything left you can
trust and this study guide actually
tells you all about the Bible and the
Word of God and how you can have a
relationship with Jesus we'll send you a
free copy of that if you'd like just
simply go to a mate you can go to get it
online go to amazing facts dot o-r-g or
you can call the resource number to get
your free study guide matter of fact
this will take you through the whole
Bible study guide series and that number
is
one eight hundred eighty three five six
seven four seven that's one eight
hundred eighty five six seven four seven
as for the study guide is there anything
left you can trust it'll talk to you
about the dependability of the Word of
God and how you might be nourished by
the bread of life all right we're gonna
try to take a call here we've got Kerry
Kerry can you hear me good we had a
little phone trouble and your question
tonight I thank you for taking my call I
greatly appreciate it the question that
I have is what would be some good
passages in order to bring how this
influence in my life I'm currently
feeling kind of lost and I'm feeling
kind of down and kind of negative I
would just like to know what would be
some encouraging you know verses that I
would be able to read to be able to
promote that positive encouragement that
I need well jesus loves you that then I
would hope you know God is love and the
Bible says in Romans eight there's
nothing that can separate you from the
love of God let me give you another
verse here in Jeremiah chapter 29 and
I'm gonna go there right now and read
this to you and you can start with verse
11 he's and this is for everybody he
said I know that plans the thoughts that
I think toward you says the Lord
thoughts of peace and not of evil to
give you a future and a hope
you know God wants the best for us and
that's why he sent His Son Jesus said he
wants us to have an abundant life now
that peace and happiness you're longing
for you don't get it just by reading a
verse you get it by believing the verses
and saying I believe God's got a good
plan for me and he will activate his
power and his love in your life how do
you asked him to do that yeah yes I have
and well you know don't be discouraged
if sometimes as a Christian you you have
ups and downs because you know there are
mountains and valleys the Bible says in
every person's life and the Bible
promises God is not only there on the
mountaintops he's there in the valleys
as well
so yeah did you were you able to jot
down some of those verses yes yes yes I
did I quickly wrote them down and you
know I really appreciate it so much you
know and and it gives me some
hopefulness and actually by reading
those to me it actually made me feel
like I have that fullness that I need
and I greatly appreciate it so much
absolutely Carrie and you go ahead and
if you go to the amazing facts website
you're gonna find a number of resources
there you get into Bible study we have
some studies that just talk about the
promises of God that's some of what I
read you and you'll be encouraged by
that so thank you for your call Kerry
all right gonna move on now and we're
going to be talking to Charles Charles
is calling from West Virginia Charles
you're on the air with Bible answers
live yes thank you is this pastor Doug
is honored to speak to you yes happy to
talk to you too yes thank you
I do have a question I wondered answer
to K into chat in chapter 28 verses 1 to
11 of Ezekiel the Prophet is told to
speak to the prince or priests of the
great city of Tyrus yeah he the Prince
the Prince says that he is a God and
such from the seat of God which is a
knee midst of many seas or Great Waters
but God says he is a man and know God
and in okay of course verse 11 to 19 it
goes on where the Prophet speaks to the
king of Tyrus and/or the head at which I
call the great red dragon could this be
the little horn of course I'm referring
to the Prince the little horn that is
found in the Book of Daniel and the
Beast of the book of Revelation well
your there is certainly a connection
here because in Ezekiel there there's
two primary Old Testament prophets that
tell about the origin or kind of give
background in Lucifer the devil and one
of them is Isaiah 14 the other is
Ezekiel 28 in both of those chapters in
Isaiah for instance
starts out talking about the king of
Babylon and then the Prophet is taken to
see the power behind the king of Babylon
and in Ezekiel he starts out talking
about the king of Tyre and then he's
taken and he looks behind the scenes at
the power behind the king of Tyre which
is the devil himself you can look for
instance in verse 6 thus says the Lord
because you set your heart as a heart of
a God behold all bring strangers against
you the most terrible of the nations
they'll draw their swords against the
beauty of your wisdom and defile your
splendor now there was an ancient
Phoenician king of Tyre but there's a
power behind the king let me give you
one more example of that if you look
Charles in Revelation chapter 12 it says
this is red dragon and this woman's
gonna have a baby and he wants to devour
the baby as soon as it's born so he
sends out a flood well we know from
history that the devil worked through
the Roman power to try to kill Jesus
when he was a baby when the Roman
soldiers went into Bethlehem and they
slaughtered all the babies right and so
here you got the devil working through
King Herod the power of Rome entire and
Babel and the devil was working the
prophets pull aside the veil and they
show these powers in the background now
one reason that you know that is he read
in Ezekiel chapter 13 he says you were
in Eden the garden of God well the king
of Tyre was not in the Garden of Eden
but the devil was right see what I'm
saying and so yeah and you read on a
little furthest he says in verse 14 you
were the anointed cherub he was a
covering cherub who covers I established
you so you are on the holy mountain of
God you walk back and forth in the midst
of the burning stones right so you as
you read a little further you say AHA
this profit is transitioned from the
king of Tyre and he's now looking at the
power behind that king that was
persecuting God's people
same thing in Isaiah 14 same thing in
Revelation chapter 12 so does that help
a little I don't it so the devil is also
behind the man of sin and the Beast
power but Ezekiel 28 isn't specifically
talking about that
you know there's a lesson that I'd be
happy to send you Charles it's called
did God create a devil and if you go to
our website you can download it for free
at amazing facts dot o-r-g or call our
resource line we'll send it to you and
at people if they wonder why is there a
devil where'd he come from it talks
about these very verses you're asking
and that number 883 five six seven four
seven that's 808 three five six seven
four seven all right thank you very much
Charles and we do have other lines open
if you have a Bible question give us a
call a free phone call that number is
eight hundred four six three seven two
nine seven that's same as eight hundred
God says that'll bring you right here to
the studio I want to say hello to our
friends I sometimes forget that we're
streaming live on Facebook and you can
go to the amazing facts Facebook page
and you'll see the live stream of the
program I've got a big empty seat over
here is pastor Ross is not with us
tonight and so we're doing our best to
keep everything juggling
[Music]
stay tuned Bible answers live we'll
return in a moment
[Music]
journey back through time to the center
of the universe discover how a perfect
angel transformed into Satan the
arch-villain the birth of evil a
rebellion in heaven
a mutiny that moved to earth
behold the creation of a beautiful new
planet and the first humans witness the
temptation of evil discover God's
amazing plan to save his children this
is a story that involves every life on
Earth every life
the cosmic conflict if God is good if
God is all-powerful if God is love then
what went wrong
once a know God's plan for our world and
solutions for your life's challenges
beautifully redesigned amazing facts 27
Bible study guides provide encouraging
Bible based answers to questions on
healthier relationships when Jesus will
return and much more refer to watch
while you read our brand new prophecy
encounters DVD series makes the perfect
companion set order your study guides
and DVDs today by visiting AAF bookstore
com or by calling 858 seven two seven
five every Bible question you have
answered moves you one step closer to
the fullness of God's will for your life
so what are you waiting for get the
answers you need for a fuller richer
more confident life you're listening to
Bible answers live
this broadcast is a previously recorded
episode if you'd like answers to your
Bible related questions on the air
please call us next Sunday between 7
p.m. and 8 p.m. Pacific time to receive
any of the Bible resources mentioned in
this evening's program call 888-814-3923
the Prophet says the soul that sins will
die and so you know a soul biblically is
the combination of God's breath of life
like when God made Adam he took the
elements of the earth the material and
then he breathed into it the breath of
life and the combination of the organic
with the power or breath of God and by
the word that word breath there it means
the spirit he breathe into an ocean of
life becomes a living soul now when any
creature dies you've got the reverse of
creation you've got in Ecclesiastes it
says the spirit returns to God who gave
it
and the elements the dust returns to the
earth you remember God said to Adam dust
you are an unto dust you'll return so at
that point you might say well you know
the soul ceases to be a soul you could
say the soul is dead until the
resurrection
right so now some churches have tried to
create a limbo or a purgatory or this
sort of a waiting room where you're kind
of disembodied spirits until the
resurrection Bible doesn't really it's a
stretch to teach that the Bible doesn't
teach that there's souls that are
floating around biblical Ani yeah so
jesus said you know you we sleep in and
sleep is usually because you're
unconscious you sleep until the
resurrection very good that's why all
the old graves used to say r.i.p rest in
peace and the old Christians understood
that you sleep until the resurrection
morning another reason is why would a
disembodied soul go to heaven or hell
before the judgment and the judgment
still in the future so yeah so that all
that's all ahead of us hey you know we
have a great study guide on this I'll be
happy to send you Jim
and it's called are the dead really dead
and it talks about the soul and death
and the very things we're talking about
you or anybody out there if you'd like
to better understand what the Bible says
about the subject of death and the soul
and the spirit and the resurrection and
the judgment we will send you that study
guide are the dead really dead
now that's an important study guide
because some people think after folks
die they turn into ghosts that go around
and haunt the Bible says that is not
true and so everyone's kind of
preoccupied with ghosts these days and
spirits and talking to their dead
relatives and Bible says that is
forbidden we shouldn't be involved in
mediums and trying to do that so it's
good for everyone who believes the Bible
to understand what does happen when you
die by the way there's about a hundred
percent death rate in the world and you
might want to know what's ahead if you
like that study guide then just call 808
three five six seven four seven we'll
send one to you or you can download it
at amazing facts dot o-r-g and that's
free
[Music]
stay tuned Bible answers live we'll
return in a moment
[Music]
amazing facts offers some of the best
Christian resources for all ages we help
our products will enrich your life and
your walk with the Lord dance a subject
everyone thinks about but no one enjoys
talking about is there life after death
the afterlife mystery is a brand new
sharing magazine that answers all your
questions get yours today by calling
[Music]
throughout recorded history tales of
ghosts and spirits can be found in
folklore in nearly every country and
culture the Egyptians built pyramids to
help guide the spirits of their leaders
Rome sanctioned holidays to honor and
appease the spirits of their dead even
the Bible tells of a king that used a
witch to contact the spirit of a
deceased prophet today ancient folklore
of spirits and apparitions have gone
from mere superstitions to mainstream
entertainment and reality scientific
organisations investigate stories of
hauntings and sightings trying to prove
once and for all the existence of ghosts
even with all the newfound technology
and centuries of stories all over the
world there is still no clear-cut answer
so how do we know what's true why do
these stories persist does it even
matter
we invite you to look inside and find
out for yourself visit death truth
dot-com every bible question you have
answered moves you one step closer to
the fullness of God's will for your life
so what are you waiting for get the
answers you need for a fuller richer
more confident life you're listening to
Bible answers live this broadcast is a
previously recorded episode if you'd
like answers to your Bible related
questions on the air please call us next
Sunday between 7 p.m. and 8 p.m. Pacific
time to receive any of the Bible
resources mentioned in this evening's
program call 888-814-3923 inton it-- the
Bible says that Joshua versa
Moses Minister and he went excuse me he
went up the mountain Saints Moses did
ten commandments right Almonte no no did
Moses Joshua fast 40 days for forty
nights since Moses you know it's a good
question I I did a sermon series on
Joshua you can actually listen to that
on youtube or download it for free but I
came to the conclusion Joshua must have
brought some food up there with him he
must have made occasional trips down the
mountain went up and he waited because
when the people made the golden calf
Joshua met Moses somewhere along the way
Joshua did not know what was happening
in the camp so Joshua wasn't up there
right with Moses when he was talking to
God and he wasn't at the base so Joshua
was something of what you would call a
medium he was in between which is
interesting because the name Josh
is the same as the name Jesus and Jesus
is a mediator he goes between us and God
yeah so I think probably took some photo
shoot up there with him the reason I was
thinking that he probably did fast it's
cuz you he maybe you're getting ready to
do is you know take most of this place
and he was one of the twelve one of the
two that didn't wanna yeah that's right
he's one of the Scourge he was being
prepared to take most of this place
that's why I thought maybe he fasted for
you may have a point theory hey we're
gonna have to just we're gonna have to
call this off right now crystal because
we're heading into a break that I can't
control and so I thank you for your
phone call and take a look online you
for the the series on Joshua I think
you'll be blessed by that
hey listening friends not going away
we're just gonna get a drink of water
and have station ID be right back
[Music]
stay tuned Bible answers live we'll
return in a moment
[Music]
did you know that Noah was present to
the birth of Abraham okay maybe he
wasn't in the room but he was alive and
probably telling stories about his
floating zoo from the creation of the
world to the last day events of
Revelation Bible history calm is a free
resource where you can explore major
Bible events and characters enhance your
knowledge of the Bible and draw closer
to God's Word go deeper visit Bible
History com okay friends let's start
with the basics
we know we're here but we're not here
for very long so the most important
thing would be if we could learn during
this life how to live forever this is
the central focus of amazing facts
there's a lot of wonderful things that
Christian ministries do I believe in
Christian education but if the school's
lose the message of salvation you end up
with more educated sinners I think it's
very important for us to build churches
but if the churches lose the message of
salvation they just become buildings and
shells I think it's important to have a
medical ministry and build hospitals but
if they separate that from the message
of salvation you just prolong a sinners
life for a little while that's why for
years amazing facts has made it our
focus to present the saving truth that
sets people free and Friends we want to
thank you for your support in your gifts
we'll do our very best to convert those
resources into the currency of heaven
may God bless you and keep amazing facts
in your prayers once you know God's plan
for our world and solutions for your
life's challenges
beautifully redesigned amazing facts 27
Bible study guides provide encouraging
Bible based answers to questions on
healthier relationships when Jesus will
return and much more refer to watch
while you read our brand new prophecy
encounters DVD series makes the perfect
companion set order your study guides
and DVDs today by visiting AAF bookstore
com or by calling 858 7275
[Music]
every bible question you have answered
moves you one step closer to the
fullness of God's will for your life so
what are you waiting for get the answers
you need for a fuller richer more
confident life you're listening to Bible
answers live this broadcast is a
previously recorded episode if you'd
like answers to your Bible related
questions on the air please call us next
Sunday between 7 p.m. and 8 p.m. Pacific
time to receive any of the Bible
resources mentioned in this evening's
program call 888-814-3923
yes my question has to do with Ephesians
chapter 6 verse 2 which says honor thy
father and thy mother
and then also Ephesians chapter 5 verse
31 which says that we are supposed to
you know husband and wife are to leave
father and mother and cleave one to
another and they shall be one flesh
yeah so what you what specifically are
you wondering about those two verses
Leon did you bump your mute button
I see Leon still here but I tell you
what I heard you read the verses so let
me do my best to give you an answer of
course we should honor our parents but
that doesn't mean you violate a Bible
principle in doing it if heaven forbid
that your parents were asking you to do
something that was immoral or
wrong you should not do that you know
first of course we want to honor our
Father in heaven and of course you know
the Bible says honoring your father and
mother it's the first commandment with
promise and the promise is that your
days will be long upon the land which
the Lord your God gives you it's
interesting that some of the nations of
the world that show the greatest respect
for their ancestors many of the Asian
countries also have the longest life
expectancies so God does still honor his
word so Leon I don't know why let me try
you one more time here yeah you there
Leon hey I think I got you back the
question specifically was because my
mother does not want to have anything to
do with my wife and my child but she
wants to be able to talk to me and have
a relationship with me but I guess I
wanted to know how do I honor her
without dishonouring my wife that is
difficult well first of all I would talk
to your wife and say you know we got a
difficult difficult situation here I
want to try to maintain a relationship
with my mother and now there may be
limits on that relationship because of
what's happening at the same time of
course you want to honor and love your
wife and so hopefully you guys can have
a meeting of the minds where maybe
there'll be times where you go and you
meet and visit with your mother and it
may not be as often as she would like
her as often as you would like but until
there's some reconciliation you might
have to be a mediator between the two
okay okay yeah you hate to get to a
point where you just say all right mom
well because you you and my wife or you
just can't get along I'm not gonna ever
talk to you again you certainly don't
want to separate from your wife for your
because you have your mother because
you're one flesh now right so exactly
you got a covenant on that side so it is
difficult I've run into that before I've
seen it before where it happens with
parents and and stepchildren and
children where you know one family
member can talk to the kids and the
other if you can't talk to one of the
parents and the the one who is a
peacemaker
you know the Bible blesses the
peacemakers they have to sort of go back
and forth between the two
I understand so I just basic have to do
my best yeah exactly you know it's tough
in and yeah be like Jesus hey thank you
that's the thank you Leon appreciate
your call all right some and a in
Raleigh North Carolina Amanda you're on
the air you're on the air yeah so if
you've got a radio or something in the
background you may want to turn it down
and your question tonight my question is
where dinosaurs created by God or Satan
well when you say dinosaur the sin of a
broad term we typically think of the you
know you think of the Jurassic Park
monsters but a dinosaur was just any
great reptile and there are large
reptiles in the world today you know
everything from the Komodo dragon to
alligators they got crocodiles in the
Nile that are ginormous they can take
down the wildebeest or a zebra so you
know before the flood not only were
reptiles much bigger but Mat mammals
were huge not you know the giant
saber-toothed Tigers and mastodons and
they they had they had sloths and
beavers that were like 13 feet tall and
I've seen with my own eyes the rack of
moose that were longer than a moose is
today just so a lot of the animals
including the reptiles shrank did God
make them yes was there some maybe
interbreeding or amalgamation that was
going on before the flood perhaps God
I'm sure made a lot of animals that did
not survive now some of the some of the
animals look pretty pretty fierce but
you know a lot of the dinosaurs from
what we can tell through paleontology
they're vegetarians yeah your
brontosaurus and a lot of those large
though the biggest of the dinosaurs were
probably all vegetarians from what we
can tell so yeah but keep in mind when
God told Noah to welcome two of each
species he didn't say they had to be
full-grown I mean he could have taken
any bitty dinosaurs and you know
dinosaur egg is about the size of a
briefcase
for the big ones so I'm sure if God said
take two of every major species he took
two of every major species now keep in
mind when God said take two of
everything Noah did not take of all the
different dogs in the world today Noah
did not take two German Shepherds and
two poodles and two beagles and two
chihuahuas and two Afghans and two
Labradors they have all descended from
the same ancestors Noah probably took
two dogs like two wolf like dogs and all
the other dogs are bred from those two
dogs
so when you say dinosaurs he didn't need
to take all the different varieties he
needed to take two of the main kinds
does that make sense
yeah you didn't need to take all the
subspecies all the cats in the world
today are related lions and tigers and
leopards and mountain lions they're all
related anyway yeah I think God did make
great reptiles the Bible even talks
about the Leviathan and it also talks
about the behemoth and so there were
some big creatures hope that helps and
by the way Amanda amazing facts carries
a it's a comic Bible study it's actually
got illustrations so I call it that and
it talks about the dinosaurs if you look
at the amazing facts website you will
see that there thank you for your call
and I move on now talk to Rogers who's
calling from is it Arvada Colorado yes
hi you're on the air Roger and your
question yes in Revelation 13 verse 18
is it the same as the little horn in
Daniel all right let's go there real
quick revelation 13 and verse 18 yes
with these powers well let me see here
yeah the beast power Revelation chapter
13 18 where it says his numbers like the
number of a man that's the same beast
power you're gonna find there in Daniel
chapter 7 verse 25 or it says he thinks
to change times and laws and you've got
the same beast power in Daniel 8 see
Daniel actually has four visions
that talk about these different powers
you got Daniel chapter 2 Daniel 7 Daniel
8 and then you've got 10 through 12
which is pretty much a distinct vision
so yeah 8 & 9 go together so all of
those the last power that they talk
about is the beast power now I think
you've got your radio on in the
background Roger you're gonna have to
turn that down because you'll get
confused by the delay does that make
sense yes it does you know I've got a
study I can send you on that and it's
absolutely free and it's talks about who
is the Antichrist and if you'd like a
free copy not just you Roger but anybody
listening out there if you'd like a free
copy of the amazing fact study guide on
what the Bible says about who is the
Antichrist
you can call we'll send you a copy you
can do yourself that's eight hundred
eight three five six seven four seven or
go to the website that's amazing facts
dot o-r-g in fact you could probably go
and watch my presentation on who the
Antichrist is well you got to do these
days it's just do YouTube Doug Batchelor
Antichrist and probably two or three
sermons will pop up you go to the
amazing facts YouTube page and you'll
find out more there thank you appreciate
your call Roger
moving on to dawn and Brandon Florida
dawn you're on the air with Bible
answers life hello my question is could
you give me a clear distinction between
Hebrews Jews and Israelites that's a
brilliant question I'm glad you asked
that question no one's ever asked it
before but as a Jew I'll do my best to
answer that for you a Hebrew is a
descendant from Abraham the descendants
of Ishmael and the other children
Abraham had by cateura were all called
Hebrews they believed that it dates back
to one of the ancestors called Eber and
the word Hebrew means crossed over
because Abraham left her of the Cowley's
and crossed the great river Euphrates
they were referred to the people that
crossed over you remember Joseph is
called a Hebrew now an Israelite they
are the descendants of Jacob you could
be
Hebrew and being related to Esau but
you're not an Israelite because you're
not coming from Jacob and so to be an
Israelite you had to be a descendant of
Jacob whose name was later changed to
Israel the word Jew is a derivative of
the word Judah because after Babylon
carried the tribe of Judah Benjamin and
Levi to captivity they came back most of
the Israelites were carried off to
Assyria many of them intermarried and
never did come back and so the Jews sort
of became that the tribe of Judah sort
of then rien habited the Land of Israel
and but the word Jew also encompasses
descendants from the tribe of Levi
Benjamin and now any of those from
Assyria that are remnants of the ten
tribes they call themselves Jews now but
the word comes from the tribe of Judah
so that's a great question and I'm glad
you've asked it you're the first one
does that make sense
it's it's still a little confusing
because it seems like the lines of
distinction have been blurred over the
years especially over the Jews I mean
well a Jew every Jew is also a Hebrew
and he's also an Israelite because the
Jews are from the tribe of Judah but it
was possible to be a Hebrew and not be a
Jew anyone related to Abraham was a
Hebrew you could also be an Israelite
and not technically a Jew if you're from
the tribe of Issachar well you're not a
Jew from the tribe of Judah but they
sort of adopted the name but you know
I've got a book I can send you on that
for free and it's called spiritual
Israel it gives a little history of
Israel and all you've got to do is call
808 three five six seven four seven dawn
ask for that book on spiritual Israel or
you can download it for free at amazing
facts dot o-r-g
[Music]
stay tuned Bible answers live we'll
return in a moment
have you ever wondered how can I share
Jesus with my Jewish friends amazing
faxes recently produced a fascinating
three-part DVD series called is Jesus
kosher for Jews in these new programs
three Jews Steve Wahlberg Jeff sir
Minsky and myself relate our personal
encounter with a Christian faith so pick
up a copy today for yourself and share
one with your Jewish friends call 800
five three eight seven 275 or visit us
at AAF bookstore com to get yours
amazing fax offers some of the best
Christian resources for all ages we have
our products will enrich your life and
your walk with the Lord
what does Bible prophecy reveal about
the world's two largest religions
explore the ancient conflict in Islam
Christianity and prophecy a compelling
three-part series with pastor Doug
Batchelor get yours today by calling
[Music]
this broadcast is a previously recorded
episode if you'd like answers to your
Bible related questions on the air
please call us next Sunday between 7
p.m. and 8 p.m. Pacific time to receive
any of the Bible resources mentioned in
this evening's program call 888-814-3923
misinterpreted but my question goes like
this I was watching a movie about Jesus
quite some time ago
and during the Sermon on the Mount
someone asked him what I thought was a
good question said rabbi if you are who
they say you are why don't you get rid
of the Romans and I thought that was a
great question you know sometimes people
say even evangelicals
maybe the Jews didn't do the right thing
by Jesus but you never hear the other
side of that coin you know I'm saying
right you heard my answer to the
previous caller I am Jewish I did not oh
well I am a Jewish Christian I grew up
in New York City and so I appreciate
where you're coming from there see Jesus
when even the apostles they were all
Jewish the Apostle said to Jesus after
he rose from the dead will you at this
time establish the kingdom are you going
to conquer the Romans and reassert
yourself on the throne of David they
were wondering what was taking Jesus so
long and Jesus had to explain to him he
said look my kingdom is not of this
world he said if my kingdom was of this
world My servants would fight that's
what he told Pontius Pilate you know he
was accused by his enemies they said oh
you're trying to make yourself a king he
said not that kind of King
is my kingdom is gonna cover the world
the Messiah is gonna be much bigger than
just the king of one country I'm gonna
be king of the world and and so he said
it's a spiritual Kingdom when Jesus
began preaching he said the kingdom of
heaven is at hand
so Christ's message was to save us from
the tyranny of sin and he was saying
yeah exactly you know he knew Rome would
fall but you know the Jew is still alive
ancient Rome is gone people don't speak
Latin anymore you know the Babylonians
the Jews survived Babylon the
Babylonians are gone the Egyptians
ancient Egyptians don't exist the people
living there now they they can't read
the hieroglyphics we might be very much
of an essay written by by Mark Twain
because it's almost exactly parallel to
that yeah Mark Twain actually visited
Israel in his journey around the world
well you've got the right idea it's it's
the Kingdom you would enjoy my book I'd
love to send you a free copy if that's
ok Phil it's called spiritual Israel and
call this number if you can write it
down 800 eight three five six seven four
seven I'll give it to you again 800
eight three five six seven four seven or
just go to amazing facts dot o-r-g and
download spiritual israel written by
myself and steve wahlberg another fellow
Jewish Christian thank you for your call
Phil gonna try and get a couple more in
talking to Bill in Psalm pain Illinois
bill you're on the air with Bible
answers live hi thanks for taking my
call okay starting with Matthew the book
met book of Matthew chapter 19 verse 1
and it came to pass that when Jesus had
finished these sayings he departed from
Galilee and came unto the border of
Judea beyond the Jordan and great
multitudes followed him and He healed
them there verse 3 the Pharisees also
came unto him testing or tempting him
and saying unto Him is it lawful for a
man to put away his wife for
because and he answered and said unto
them have ye not read that he who made
them at the beginning made them male and
female and said for this cause shall a
man shall shall a man leave father and
mother and shall cleave to his wife and
they too shall be one flesh
there's a question they say in him why
did Moses then command to give a writing
of divorcement and to put her away and
he saith unto them Moses because of the
hardness of your hearts permitted you to
put away your wives but from the
beginning it was not so
so that means divorce should not be
period
sounds like Jesus is objective and
totally against divorce there's some
laws that God made in the Bible that
were not part of God's perfect will God
never intended for people to enslave one
another but in the culture back in the
days of Moses everyone had slaves so God
made laws to treat the slaves kindly and
with fairness and like keeping the
Sabbath and other things ears never
God's law for a man to have more than
one wife but it was prevalent and so God
made laws about treating people fairly
it was never God's law for people to
divorce never his will but because of
the hardness of their hearts he made
laws about that
so you'll find another number of places
where you're right it's not God's will
for anyone to divorce but here's my
point sir I mean I had no idea about
this actually no Christian should ever
get a divorce well Jesus that's legal
Jesus said there is for a Christian he
says there is one reason for divorce and
that was he says the cause of
fornication he says that in Matthew
chapter 5
Jesus said no one should divorce saving
for the cause of fornication in other
words if a man leaves his wife and he
goes off with another woman he's had
broken the vow she's then free okay so
if there is one at least one reason that
Jesus says fornication okay yeah but
this whole business of no-fault divorce
or abuse or anything else according to
Scripture
no way fornication
maybe but that's it so I'm just blown
away by this that's all yeah that you
will your your scene what a lot of
people have seen too late that it was
never God's will for people to treat
marriage the Covenant of marriage is to
be a sacred eternal thing I've performed
a lot of marriages and we usually say
until death do you part
hey thank you very much bill I do have a
book if you'd like a free copy it's
called marriage divorce and remarriage
dealing with our exact topic and you can
call amazing facts and just call 883
five six seven four seven and you can
ask for that book marriage divorce and
remarriage talking next - got time for
maybe one more question here may and
Tampa Florida may are you there yes and
you got a question yes
hi so I was wondering so I know that we
are sons and daughters of God are safe
by grace how do you know that in the end
times you won't be deceived because you
can study lots of prophecy and you can
study the Bible as much as you want but
there still may be that potential that
you may be deceased in the end time so
how do you make sure that you know
enough or how do you know that you won't
be deceived in the end time well the way
that Jesus avoided deception of the
devil is through the Word of God he
quoted the word to the devil and the
Bible tells us in Isaiah chapter 8 I
believe it's verse 16 according to the
law and the testimony that's the law of
the prophets the Word of God if they
speak not according to this word there's
no light in them the word is a lamp to
our feet and a light to our path and so
if you know the Bible it's the genuine
you will spot the counterfeit if you
spend time in the word and you spend
time in prayer with Jesus you're going
to know the true and be able to tell the
true from the false and so boy that is
the very best thing you can do to avoid
deception of the last days this study
for yourself don't just drink in what
some pastor like myself is saying all
kinds of preachers on television and
radio and they can deceive you you need
to know for yourself by being acquainted
with God's teaching in the word you
don't have to have
doctorate in theology to understand the
Bible so how important is it to a study
other stuff other than the Bible like
this perhaps say that LNG white books
because my parents are big on those
books and I'm just wondering should we
be studying those books besides the bro
there's nothing wrong with studying
other good Christian books because you
know the main thing is you all those
books must be measured by the Bible I
for one have found that there are things
that Ellen White says are just
phenomenal and have been very encouraged
and inspired by it and there's other
good Christian authors you know I read
some of the great commentaries you can
read things by John Wesley and Martin
Luther and sometimes it's like when you
eat a watermelon you eat the melon and
you spit out the seeds right and so you
just have to and how do you know that
there's seeds you say wait that ain't
any melon well when you're when you're
reading other Christian authors if you
find anything that doesn't match with
the Bible well you just get rid of that
but they'll still be a lot of good stuff
they're read the word I'm gonna see if I
could squeeze it oh you know I don't
know if I'm gonna have time to squeeze
in another question may if you're still
listening please sign up for that call
and sign up for the free Bible study
guide that I offer tonight the amazing
facts Bible study guides if you call
that number 883 five six seven four
seven they'll send you the first few
lessons you do those you will know your
Bible and you'll know how to resist
temptation in the last days you will not
be deceived that's why the amazing facts
Bible study course has been a
best-seller for about thirty five years
and we've just completely redone the
lessons one more time anyone would like
to sign up for the amazing fact study
guides eight hundred eight three five
six seven four seven you know I probably
I see a few people lined up all right
Chris we got one minute are you on the
air Chris Chris and Chicago Illinois are
you there you may be Chris you may be
all right well you know Chris is not
picking up hey listening friends I want
to just remind you that so much of what
we offer is of
available through amazing facts dot
o-r-g and we have a brand new website if
you've not been to the amazing facts web
site in the last couple of weeks you're
going to be refreshed and surprised when
you see it it's very easy to navigate as
attractive it's got some video right
there in the in the opener just go to
amazing fact so our G and we have a
brand new amazing facts app it's been
approved it's on the Apple phones now
it'll be going live on Samsung it might
be live now I haven't checked lately but
the amazing facts app you just go to
your App Store and you type in amazing
facts ministry go to the store amazing
facts ministry download the app it'll
tell you when there's exciting things
happening and a lot more besides that
god bless you friends and remember Jesus
is the truth
thank you for listening to today's
broadcast
we hope you understand your Bible even
better than before Bible answers live is
produced by amazing facts a faith-based
ministry located in Sacramento
California
[Music]
want to know God's plan for our world
and solutions for your life's challenges
beautifully redesigned amazing facts 27
Bible study guides provide encouraging
Bible based answers to questions on
healthier relationships when Jesus will
return and much more refer to watch
while you read our brand new prophecy
encounters DVD series makes the perfect
companion set order your study guides
and DVDs today by visiting AAF bookstore
calm or by calling 858 7 2 7 5 if you've
missed any of our amazing facts programs
visit our website at amazing facts org
there you'll find an archive of all our
television and radio programs including
amazing facts presents 1 location so
many possibilities amazing facts org
terror attacks natural disasters
political instability and global
economic meltdown these are the images
people generally associate with the
tribulation and the day of the Lord but
did you know the Bible speaks about
another day of the Lord just before the
great Judgment Day amazingly imprinted
on the very fabric of time itself is a
24-hour period called the Sabbath that
was meant to forever be a time of
restoration for every human being a day
the entire world is largely forgotten
you'll be surprised to learn how this
special day of the Lord
factors into last day prophecies such as
the mark of the beast the seal of God
and the great final tribulation it's all
contained in this new eye-opening DVD
series called the last day of prophecy
to order call 800 538 7 to 75 or visit
AF bookstore com
[Music]
for over 50 years
amazing faxes shared the wonderful news
of salvation and provided millions of
Bible resources to people all over the
world
we built churches in India proclaim
God's Word in China and have sent free
Bible studies around the globe today's
program and free resources were made
possible by our ministry partners caring
individuals like you if you've been
blessed by amazing facts would you
please consider partnering with us to
reach others with a Bible truth your
financial support today will help keep
programs like this on the air so the
blessings you've received can be shared
with others to find out more about
becoming a ministry partner please visit
our website to take advantage of the
offers you've heard on this broadcast
call us at
you